well Carly if there was any doubt that
we're backstage at a music festival
boots and hearts party is up on stage
right now
a little louder he's loud hearty shut up
we're underneath the tree adjoining so
welcome to boots and heart thank you so
what's the festival life like for you
like as a different furniture I mean
there's more artists and I think it
feels a little bit more like summer camp
just the backstage area and I think it's
really cool you never know who you're
gonna be on a festival bill with and I
think that's fun yeah do you find the
crowd is different at a festival yes
maybe they came to see one of the acts
on the bill I think you know they didn't
buy a ticket just to see the tour that
you're a part of it so like we're like
2:30 right now a lot of hours to go I
did spell deed so I saw the photograph
like on Friday so he was here on Friday
you're here Sunday so you managed to
hook up in New York but like how hard is
it for you guys to carve the time of the
CETA
it's hard yeah you kind of just have to
make it work
so 15 hours you had to come to me
now we won't see each other for a while
but when you find that person you just
make it work and you figure out that
home is where they are is not your home
anymore
right now how's the wedding planning
coming I know you're doing most of it
with your mom you said you just wanted
an open bar and you wanted like simple
outfits for his groomsmen okay good it's
going really well
really close we're like down to the to
the end of it all so everything's pretty
much said and just doing the little
things now like have you found time to
do that while you're touring a lot of us
right so I can do stuff and when I'm in
Nashville I just try to focus on that it
just hopefully when I show up it's all
done yeah exactly
and he was saying to that Jay Cohen's
gonna do the first time which is pretty
amazing look exactly like that Jake's
gonna do the first song we love his song
made for you and it was so sweet of him
to mark it off on his calendar so many
months ago and say that he wanted to be
there so we're excited yeah now so when
I talked to Michael I said what question
should I ask Carly okay so his question
is can he have three more people come to
the wedding
that is not nice to do this to me on
camera I hate you
it's been it's been difficult with sweet
Michael having a huge family right and
as we go along I gave him a cutoff and
as we've gotten closer there's little
special people that just all the sudden
we're showing up that I have no idea who
they are
but they're so important to it but I'm
pretty sure I granted you those three
people actually better not be plural in
a wedding is just oh you got to invite
that person you gotta write that person
L know it's done
plus I look closer to you the new single
so what was what so special at this time
for you
I think this is my this process
obviously was all of the changes of my
life the way that people embrace my
first record but I fell in
that I'm that person that minutes been
my life witness I just wanted to release
something that was just celebratory of
that and kind of just a transitional
song to get you to see my next record
I've just this is how I'm feeling right
now which is it do you feel the pressure
with a sophomore album yes yes like how
do you deal with that um you have less
time to make it you're like 35,000 times
busier so that makes it harder but I
think for me it also is a positive that
I know what fans want for me when
they've embraced me so much and showed
me that they want that authentic raw
real storytellers singer countries are
all sound from me and so that's maybe
like more confident to go do what I know
I do best
is it done is there any way to change
anything in this corner said he'll
deliver okay does that nerve-wracking to
know like you can't change anything
yeah but also I think I'm now past the
point of being nervous and I'm just
really excited to get her out
now the closer to you music we don't
like Michael is in there like a little
cameo at the end yeah that was funny
interesting to talk to that about
artists like to have your significant
other in this video cos like would it be
a weird thing at this point to have like
an actor player love interest sweet but
decided we'll never do that again either
it just be the narrator's of the video
and let other people actor will be in
each other's videos yeah it just feels
weird and I feel like fans would it
would feel very fake obviously we both
have had love interest before but now
and especially because we're both in the
public eye elsewhere so we're just like
an hour before your show like you have
any like crucial rituals like what
you've achieved before on stage well I'm
cleaning at 4:20 today so I probably
won't drink red wine before but that's
usually what I do but you kind of try to
have a few minutes of my band just get
ready
[Music]